business is booming at the christmas
market in kingston in surrey and with an
eye on covet rates in europe there's a
sense that people are making the most of
the festive traditions whilst they can
operations manager jack botting says the
memory of cancelling last year's event
just before opening is still vivid
what we've seen is people are very happy
to have the market back in town we've
been here for a few years now we have a
lot of regular faces show up so they're
all very pleased to to come back and i
think
so far it's looked fairly busy and i
think we're looking at a bit people
trying to fit in a double christmas
the hughes family are getting together
to visit their son edison who's at
university
last year we couldn't do anything you
know we had a really small christmas so
you feel like you've missed a year
the dutch pancakes and german beers are
as popular as ever selling well here if
not in parts of europe under new
restrictions
but there's little appetite for some of
the stricter measures which are going to
be imposed across the channel to reduce
infection rates
i think maybe more more vaccine
passports but not making it mandatory to
judge people i understand that it can
help protect the elderly and the
vulnerable but again i don't think
people should be forced into doing
something
forcing people to get vaccinated has
brought demonstrations on the streets of
austria a nationwide lockdown has been
announced and controversially vaccines
will be mandatory from february
it's a worrying slide backwards but one
of the government's scientific advisors
in the uk is optimistic that may not be
britain's fate
we're in a slightly different position
um to
austria and germany and and so on
and that we've had high rates
fairly stable but very high rates for
many months and so
i think uh i don't think things will
happen quite in the same way here as
they have done there but it is a warning
to us
not enough people are being jabbed in
austria and its geographical location
close to other countries with low
take-up is part of its problem
austria has many immigrants there's a
lot of exchange in in labor between
slovakia czech republic and we have to
solve this together otherwise it will
not work for these small countries in
central europe
record infections in the netherlands
have also led to demonstrations against
new restrictions
in germany it's also starting to look
not a lot like christmas with
authorities cancelling events amidst new
covered measures
in the uk for now the government is
insisting there are no plans to curb the
countdown to christmas lisa holland sky
news